hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten willens ich habe heute kein
rezept video für euch sondern möchte
etwas ansprechen was für uns alle sehr
wichtig und vor allem im moment sehr
aktuell ist
ihr kennt mich ja als sally ich bin
verheiratet habe eine tochter und bin
grundschullehrerin
ich habe eltern die aus der türkei
gekommen sind als gastarbeiter damals
vor 40 jahren und die hier dann hat
gearbeitet haben
ich habe vier geschwister und bei meinen
eltern warst und so dass sie irgendwann
sich eine wohnung gekauft haben in dem
mehrfamilienhaus in waghäusel und damals
war es so dass wir praktisch die ersten
ausländischen bewohner dort waren und
wir durften da ganz lange zeit nicht
einziehen weil sich die bewohner damals
gegen uns praktisch gestellt haben und
unterschriften gesammelt haben dass wir
nicht einziehen dürfen und man darf den
leuten keinen vorwurf machen weil es war
ja so dass es dann neu für die leute war
sie kannten uns türken damals nicht und
hatten einfach wahrscheinlich angst das
ist jetzt mittlerweile 23 jahre her und
es war auch damals so dass wir dann
wirklich parallel in einer anderen
wohnung haben boden müssen und die
wohnung trotzdem gekauft war aber wir
dürfen einfach nicht einziehen
irgendwann war es dann so dass wir sogar
vor gericht kamen und dann durften wir
irgendwann einsehen die leute haben uns
kennengelernt sie haben es auch lieben
gelernt und heute wasser so dass ich
jetzt die lehrerin von den kindern der
kinder bin und die in der schule
unterrichtet habe ich habe ihnen deutsch
unterricht gegeben und
englischunterricht meine schwester zum
beispiel ist altenpflegerin und hat es
die menschen dort dann gepflegt mein
bruder ist elektromeister und hat gerade
vor kurzem zwei drei wochen her hat er
im ganzen haus die brandschutzanlagen
installiert und eingerichtet
und wieso erzähle ich euch dass ich
erzähle euch das war einfach da viele
vorurteile geherrscht haben die aber
später dann irgendwie einfach wegfahren
weil die menschen uns kennengelernt
haben und mittlerweile ist es so dass es
dass das ganze wohngebäude dann wie eine
große familie war man kann das sehe ich
mal liebt es sich und zwar einfach eine
schöne nachbarschaft und ich möchte
heute einfach ein thema ansprechen und
habe heute ein gast bei mir her und
möchte einfach dass wir
an dem schicksal teilhaben und uns das
anhören
ich bin 25 jahre alt und mit meiner
tochter auf der flucht und da wo ich
herkomme weit grundschullehrerin
ich hab mein heimatland verlassen ich
musste es verlassen ich wurde verfolgt
aufgrund meiner religiösen und
politischen einstellungen ich hatte noch
einen sieben jahre alten sohn doch der
wurde leider bei einem bombenanschlag
auf die schule getötet
mein mann wollte ihn retten
die beamten erschossen
auf der flucht
[Musik]
wurde ich von den soldaten fünf mal vor
den augen meiner tochter misshandelt und
vergewaltigt jetzt bin ich hier wir
haben eine lange reise hinter uns ich
habe keine kraft mehr wir haben nichts
zu essen mehr und wir wollen einfach nur
noch hilfe bitte helft uns
[Musik]